J'ai sept enfants dont trois qui sont devenus autistes
maintenant que j'ai étudié davantage de choses sur la vaccination je comprends qu'il ya un lien entre cet autisme et la vaccination. Des vidéos contre
les vaccins il y en a énormément sur internet.
L'argument c'est souvent oui ce point naturel on sait pas ce que ton genre pourquoi mettre de l'aluminium sinon pour intoxiquer les populations
alors est ce que c'est vrai sait-on seulement ce qu'il y à vraiment dans les vaccins qu'on nous injecte
parce que moi je ne sais pas pour vous et je connais plus la liste des ingrédients
derrière un paquet de serial que celle d'un vaccin avec ma tarte on va étudier le rôle de chaque ingrédient
et voir quelle est la cause des problèmes induits par la vaccination vous allez voir c'est fascinant
Qu'est ce qu'il y a dans un vaccin ?
Vous connaissez le principe du vaccin on prend un virus on le désactive on te l'injecte.
Techniquement oui un vaccin c'est une piqûre de virus mort mais ça marche
votre corps détecte le virus ultra fiable y apprend le combattre et quand tu as le vrai virus balèze qui arrive ton système
immunitaire est déjà prêt pour lui foutre une grosse raclée. Ici le virus atténué est le composant
thérapeutique du vaccin. Maintenant ton virus atténué pour le transporter il faut principalement
de l'eau oui techniquement de l'eau et rien de plus. Mais voilà, un vaccin c'est un produit industriel
donc oui il existe bien des usines à vaccin.
D'ailleurs ça ressemble à ça ! Cadeau. Comme pour tes BN et ta pastabox le produit doit être conservée,
transporter puis vendues. Il faut donc éviter que ça dégrade et c'est pour ça qu'on ajoute plein d'autres éléments chimiques. J'avais raison
les vaccins c'est pas bio... oui alors non heureusement que ces trucs soi-disant nocifs sont là !
D'abord les conservateurs. Le vaccin on te l'injecte dans le corps donc vaut mieux que ça soit pur et sans bactéries. En
1916 des centaines d'enfants vaccinés contre la typhoïde ont été contaminés par un staphylocoque qui s'étaient développés dans le liquide du vaccin
Les conservateurs sont justement là pour éviter ça. Avant les années 2000 un de ces conservateurs était le thiomersal.
Et ce qui est pas cool avec lui c'est qu'il contient du mercure toxiques.
Même si les études ont montré que ce n'était pas dangereux à doses aussi infimes par prudence ce n'est plus utilisés aujourd'hui.
Enfin presque, on en trouve encore dans les anti venin est vraiment quelques rares vaccin old school contre la grippe.
Aujourd'hui les conservateurs sont plus naturelles par exemple le
2-phénoxyéthanol qu'on retrouve dans le thé vert ou la chicorée, les insecticides aussi.
Deuxième ingrédient :
les stabilisant. Les stabilisants eux vont servir à maintenir la qualité du vaccin et c'est pas des produits terrifiant.
On parle de sucre de lait de blanc d’œuf et de gélatine.
Alors je sais vous n'avez pas envie de vous piquer avec de l'actimel mais les deux sont infimes.
C'est juste pour que les virus du vaccin soit bien
Troisième ingrédient : les agents inactivateurs. Comme on vous le dit les vaccins ça reste quand même des virus
donc certains vaccins pour éviter qu'ils se réveillent commencent à se multiplier
puis à foutre le zbeul on va ajouter un produit pour le calmer direct...
Commence à me parler poliment... Le produit un activateur par excellence est malheureusement très controversé c'est un cancérigène avéré le formaldéhyde
alors si vous voulez un nom qui fais moi peur c'est le formol le liquide pour conserver des animaux morts
bon bah on en trouve absolument partout même le corps en produits à tel point que l'air que nous respirons est saturé de cette substance.
C'est l'un des produits polluants
numéro un dans l'ère des maisons y en a aussi dans certains vaccins mais bon
tellement moins que dans tout ce que vous trouverez autour de vous donc inutile de paniquer
Quatrième ingrédients : les excipients et c'est là que ça commence à chauffer
le but des excipients et de renforcer l'efficacité des vaccins
il ya des vaccins quand tu les injecte le corps ils paniquent pas trop il se dit oui bon ce virus
ça va... Mais si on met des éléments agressive dans le vaccin le corps va se mettre dans un état d' d'inflammation la panique
générale tout un système immunitaire va débouler sur le champ de bataille
s'entraîner contrôle faux virus et c'est là que le vaccin va être efficace
à la base pour les excipients on utiliser un peu n'importe quoi comme des miettes de pain ou du tapioca
je suis sérieux en injecter du tapioca
pour remplacer ça on a trouvé quelque chose de très très efficace qui marche super bien et c'est l'aluminium
l'aluminium c'est un métal lourd comme le mercure le plomb. Ton corps
l'éliminent très bien mais quand même une petite partie qui va rester dans les eaux le foie et les poumons et c'est ça qui inquiète
sauf que bon on injecte pas du papier d'alu en réalité c'est une autre molécule cette molécule c'est du sels d'aluminium
et le sel d'aluminium il y en a plein de différentes hydroxyde d'aluminium phosphate d'aluminium solfate d'aluminium
chlorhydrate d'aluminium et cetera et cetera
celui utilisé dans les vaccins c'est surtout
l'hydroxyde d'aluminium
lui il est présent dans la nature sous forme de roches comme la pierre d'alun que vous connaissez sûrement comme cosmétique
si vous avez déjà mis du déodorant ce que j'espère sachez le vous avez pris la maxi doses de sel d'aluminium
car oui l'aluminium ça fait peur mais c'est un des éléments les plus abondants de la couche terrestre
fatalement on en trouve un peu partout dans tout ce que vous mangez même dans le lait maternel
si vous donner un biberon de lait industriel vous donner autant de sel d'aluminium que ce qu'il y a dans un vaccin
injecté de l'aluminium en quantités aussi un film n'a donc rien de criminel
Quels sont les effets secondaires dangereux des vaccins on l'a vu dans la partie précédente
oui les vaccins ont déjà tué le cas le plus impressionnant c'est l'accident de cutter
encore aujourd'hui c'est considéré comme l'un des plus grands désastres
pharmaceutique de l'histoire des états unis alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé en
1955 les vaccins du laboratoire cutter contre la polio
contenait la polio. Les virus censé être désactivée ne l'était pas vraiment plus de
40000 infections des bébés mort-nés des paralysies des décès ça a été une catastrophe
mais voilà aujourd'hui les normes de sécurité des vaccins sont drastiques
plus de staphylocoques qui traînent plus de virus non désactivé et pourtant
certaines personnes semblent encore mal réagir aux vaccins premier cas douleur et paralysie
imaginez vous venez de vous faire vacciner contre l'hépatite b et un simple vaccin une formalité mais soudain vous commencez à vous sentir
fatigué vous avez mal aux muscles aux articulations
perdre la mémoire qu'est-ce qui se passe c'est ce qu'on appelle une myofasciite à macrophages le premier cas a été détecté en 1996
avec comme premier suspect le sel d'aluminium dans les vaccins
sauf qu'on est sûr de rien
en fait on n'est même pas sûr que cette maladie existe en effet au total on observe le phénomène que sur 400 personnes est quasiment
qu'en france ça serait donc une maladie française
bizarre... Par exemple syndrome de guillain-barré
c'est une grave maladie neurologique qui entraîne des paralysies et peut être parfois fatales il est provoqué par une dysfonction du système immunitaire
c'est suffisant pour que quelques paranoïaque hurle sur tous les toits que les vaccins en sont la cause
un premier groupe de chercheurs a montré en 1976 que le risque d'attraper le syndrome de guillain-barré après avec saint était un
chouïa plus élevé puis entre 2000 et 2009
une autre étude a montré qu'au contraire les vaccins nous en protégerait un peu
d'où l'idée que la cause pourrait être ailleurs que dans les vaccins et son aluminium peut-être une allergie à l'aluminium
le problème c'est qu'on sait pas trop par quoi remplacer le sel d'aluminium
le candidat numéro 1 c'est le phosphate de calcium
mais il reste moins performant que l'aluminium en tout cas c'est ce qu'en disent les labos. Il y a énormément
de flou son sujet et c'est normal on veut pas créer mouvement de panique
si les gens arrêtent de se vacciner par peur on se limitera pas à 2 3 4 fatigue c'est des millions de victimes potentielles
deuxième cas l'autisme c'est une phobie qui persistent dans l'imaginaire collectif
l'idée que les vaccins provoquent l'autisme née d'un énorme scandale qui s'est déroulé dans les années
des chercheurs avec une VASTE
études sur des milliers d'enfants ont réussi à prouver que le coupable de l'autisme étaient les vaccins. Attendez j'ai dis vaste étude
ah ben non ils ont examiné des enfants l'étude est porté par un certain andrew wakefield et son travail ne dit absolument
pas que c'est lié juste que c'est possible ça aurait pu s'arrêter là mais une fois publié la
machine médiatique s'embrase et Wakefield sent le filon et il s'empresse d'organiser des conférences de presse
et devinez ce qui dit il y à un ré lien entre l'autisme et l'abattît nation
la nouvelle est jeté aux lions c'est le départ d'un incendie qui mettra des années
à s'éteindre parce qu'en fait tout est faux bah ouais on a quand même refait une étude pour vérifier au danemark entre
1999 et 2010 ces six mille cinq cents enfants qui ont développé des troubles autistiques
les chercheurs ont alors comparer le nombre d'enfants autistes parmi les vaccinés et parmi les non vaccinés
résultat pas de différence. Aucune étude n'est parvenu à mettre en lumière un quelconque lien entre
autisme et vaccination. Tout ce que vous avez entendu sur l'autisme et les vaccins sa part de ça de cette étude bidon
le journal ayant publié ces mêmes rétracter et excusé auprès de la communauté scientifique
dix ans après la publication mais bon c'était déjà ça
wakefield a été interdit de pratiquer la médecine au royaume uni et un même été rognées par ses pair... pas le choix
il a immigré aux états unis. Alors pourquoi Wakefield a fait ça ? la thune juste la thune ?
probablement pas la gloire peut-être d'avoir fait une grande découverte et d'être enfin reconnu
mais surtout là dessus parce que faut pas oublier que le gars a été payé par un cabinet d'avocats
mandatés par les familles de leur foi aux pistes afin de leur faire gagner un procès contre les fabricants de vaccins
le truc c'est qu'un procès contre les grands laboratoires ça peut rapporter gros par exemple procès contre les laboratoires pour les victimes du médiator
ces 115 millions de dollars
d'indemnisation. Le médiator était prescrit pour des victimes de diabète de niveau 2 mais aussi comme coupe faim et pour des millions de personnes
ça s'est très mal passé a du coup il y avait de l'argent à se faire
Déjà wakefield avait constitué une société dans le but de commercialiser des tests et il prévoyait d'en tirer
72,5 millions de livres par an au royaume uni et aux usa soutenu par donald trump et de nombreuses autres victimes
wakefield reçoit un fort soutien financier lui permettant de mettre leur cause sous le feu des projecteurs
du coup qui est le comploteur dans l'histoire plutôt les laboratoires ou plutôt les millionnaires soutenu par le président des états unis. Troisième cas :
l'affaiblissement génétique. Sachez le
l'adn humain
et en partie virale nous vivons car nous avons des virus en nous. Il y à 50 millions d'années un animal a été
infecté par un virus
il l'a intégré en lui. Ce virus dans son adn lui a donné la possibilité de fabriquer la protéine à l'origine du placenta
Le placenta est le liquide qui vous a permis de vous
développer dans le ventre de votre mère. Sans ce virus pas de placenta, pas de mammifère
donc pas d'humains ces virus dans notre adn ne provoque pas de maladie ils sont non pathogène mais peut-être qu'à un moment de l'histoire
il l'était c'était peut-être la grippe de l'époque qui a permis d'améliorer le
matériel génétique des humains c'est là la théorie soutenue par certains en empêchant les virus on empêche l'évolution
Certes en laissant mourir des milliers de gens on participe à une certaine sélection naturelle les plus forts survivent
mais est ce que c'est vraiment le genre d'idéologie qu'on veut encore en 2020 pas sûr
alors oui la vaccination n'est pas parfaite il y à des risques et des effets secondaires comme n'importe quel médicament ou
opérations médicales ce qui est dingue c'est que la france est reconnue pour avoir une des meilleures médecine au monde mais aussi
une des plus grandes communautés anti vaccins et vous quel est votre avis sur les vaccins laisser un petit commentaire pour partager votre opinion
pensez à vous abonner si vous souhaitez toujours plus de vidéos de séances
merci à spyke pour les recherches s'étaient pas facile c'est un sujet quand même
assez dense assez chaud et faut pas dire de bêtises ce que j'espère qu'on n'a pas fait
normalement sa devrait aller et merci de nous avoir suivis allez les amis Tchao !